We're still not actually inserting
weather data into the ContentProvider.
So, this is a good time to
talk about BulkInserts.
Remember, that BulkInsert allows
us to insert multiple rows
far more efficiently by using
a database transaction.
We can apply this when we need to
insert 14 days worth of weather data
into the table.
Use the ContentProvider to BulkInsert
the vector of content values into
the database.
Note, there are a few lines underneath
the area where you add your BulkInsert
code that you can use to test displaying
the values you just inserted.
It will read those values out of
the data base, create content values for
them, and pass them into the same
display function we already have.